how could a movie with this cast this
director a premise that involves kicking
Hitler's butt and a title like the
monuments men be anything less than
monumental the monuments men is directed
by George Clooney and stars him Matt
Damon Jean Dujardin John Goodman Bob
Balaban Bill Murray Kate Blanchet this
cast is absurdly great and this is a
movie that has a lot of great noble
intentions it tells the true story of
very brave men who went into enemy lines
when the Nazi war was raging to rescue
art pieces that Hitler was hell-bent on
stealing to create this Fuhrer Museum
this story is based on things that
really did happen I mean Hitler took
everything from people especially their
valuables to me the monuments men was a
sure bet I mean I've really liked George
Clooney's films in the past Ides of
March I thought was fantastic obviously
the acting pedigree in the movie is
great the trailers look good and then it
got pushed back to February when it was
originally going to come out more around
Oscar time and they were saying it had
something to do with special effects and
needing him to be completed and you know
some people were like well no no no I
gotta say this movie is kind of a
letdown was very disappointed by this
movie this movie is actually pretty
bland and kind of boring to be honest
it's the kind of film where as you're
watching and it feels like a whole bunch
of exposition as if okay we're leading
up to the point where the movie starts
okay and this scene we're leading up to
the point where the movie starts oh okay
we're now 70 minutes into the movie and
it still feels like it hasn't really
started yet that's not a good feeling
now as I said the true story of what
happened these guys is completely noble
the film has great intentions I wouldn't
say it's an offensive film at all if
anything it's actually a little too
sweet I understand that it's going for
more crowd pleasing happy vibe but
unfortunately the film comes off a
little bit too melodramatic because of
that at times and I really just feel
like the characters in the film were
very dull I didn't really care about
anybody I didn't really see any one that
wasn't oh that's George Clooney running
right there oh that's Matt Damon oh
that's you know John Goodman with a gun
it's like none of it really felt like I
was watching actual characters it just
felt like I was watching a whole bunch
of famous people having a good time
acting here it felt like I really needed
some characters and this just felt like
a great assemblage of a-list actors that
weren't really portraying characters and
it's not any fault of their acting
talent it's actually the script the
scripts characters just weren't really
that fleshed out they felt very cookie
cutter one-dimensional to me there are
great aspects to this movie it looks
very nice although I do think it should
have been edited more tightly to
preserve a better pacing the acting is
great especially Cate Blanchett I would
say she's the one character in this
movie that truly did feel like a
character and I didn't really see Cate
Blanchet as much as I saw her character
and I think she did a very good job in
this movie the score is really good the
story is interesting I was definitely
invested in the story and what they were
trying to do I think it's a very very
cool story they have during this movie
but for the most part the movie comes
off as kind of bland and that's
unfortunately due to the fact that the
film's script just doesn't feel as if it
has the weightiness that it should the
direction is a little bit slack and
unfortunately I got to give the
monuments men a C+ I think it could have
been a lot better than it was the acting
is good I just didn't really see any
characters in the movie but it still is
an enjoyable film that perhaps one day
you could rent and watch and enjoy so
guys if you saw the monuments been what
did you think of it let me know below
and as always if you liked this you can
click right here and get stuck Minh iced
[Music]
so guys as I mentioned last month in my
review for her the website audible.com
has decided they like my videos they
could have picked other people's videos
but they like mine they want to sponsor
me they want to help me they also want
to help you through me they're allowing
anyone who wants to to download a free
audio book of their choice for any book
that they find interesting they gave me
my own custom URL that's audible.com
slash Chris it's literally no
requirement to you can do whatever you
want if you want to listen to one of
your favorite books and have a famous
person read to you you can I listen to
carry by Sissy Spacek it was great
that's audible.com slash Kris if you
want to check that out thanks as always
guys